[Music]
thank you I look cute on TV I ain't even
know I've been trying to lose weight man
cuz I like I like all type of women you
know what I mean like like the only type
of woman I don't like is the ugly woman
I'm just saying I can't be fat you ugly
and we walk around looking like a
science project people trying to catch
us like Pokemon I don't got i like all
type of women like I like like I I like
big girls I do you know yeah big girls
always like some dessert you ain't had
in a long time you have a hug one I'm
like is that really okay
two big people having sex is falling it
just don't make an attractive noise it
sound like a whole bunch of wet
handshakes
like a locker room full of high five by
hey good game good good they want
undefeated they went undefeated that's
what you got to think about stuff man I
was thinking like what if what if I get
a big girl pregnant right and the baby
grow up start to walk and run and we
can't catch it will literally be unfit
parents you know what a man like you
know how embarrassing not to be my
comics without a missing person report
like sir when she realized her baby was
missing I'm like immediately I was right
here I was right then when he ran off
I'm from Virginia I used to be a server
I used to I used to be a server at IHOP
place to workout huh you know how hard
it is to smoke weed be big and take
orders it felt like me and the customers
was always having foreplay never like
yeah can I get the pancakes
maybe like buttermilk then they get into
it and I get him to get my egg scramble
with cheese I'm like what kind they like
provolone like provolone I never did it
with the provolone people judgmental I'm
a big dude I know that I used to hate
having it on the table we out of what
they want to order it's automatically my
fault no matter what it is I had a lady
order turkey bacon one day I'm like
ma'am I'm so sorry we're all out of
Turkey Baker she don't look me up and
down I bet y'all all right it's her like
I like regular bacon make your blood
pressure go up you got to get your foot
cut off that's the bacon
[Applause]
and Jessica something's on the menu
don't mean you got to order it like IHOP
sale t-bones but if you don't have
health insurance turn to page I had this
lady order a t-bone one day is how
arrogant she acted that made me upset
she was like um yes I would like to chew
bone could you tell the chef I like a
medium-rare a dude at another table was
like did she say chef I'm like ear dog
she trippin hold on I got this I got
this
[Applause]
I'm like first off you want your t-bone
from haha that's what this joke should
hand I'm talking I'm like you want your
t-bone from IHOP anything other than
well-done I'm lead you signed this
health waiver cuz we didn't even get
this off a truck we got this out the
trunk of her own ein Honda Accord
and it ain't never been a chef a tie
this is a brother named brie on back he
didn't study abroad nah he killed a
brother
[Applause]